tu es payé en fonction de ce que tu
rapportes donc par exemple nous on est
payé en fonction de ce qu'on rapporte de
la publicité etc
il gagne pas beaucoup d'argent
il y a des acteurs sur payer qui sont
financés même publiquement etc qui font
des films qui ne rapportent rien et donc
c'est il y a un sentiment d'injustice
c'est pas que vous avez balancé mon
salaire sur TPMP la semaine dernière
nous oui vous vous êtes bien la personne
en question c'est vous madame moi j'ai
balancé le salaire de qui le mien
ah le vôtre
quels étaient les salaires sur TF1
c'était énorme vous aviez combien 100000
certains mois pas tous les mois mais il
y avait des 1000 euros
mais je vais vous expliquer mais vous
allez savoir 2002 en 2008 contrat
d'exclusivité
j'ai gagné 30000 € j'avais 30000 d'excus
je sais pas comment vous êtes sur 5 mois
j'avais 5 mois c'est 5000 balles oui
c'est bien pour pas qu'elle est d'accord
voilà c'était pour pas partir mais à
l'époque ça maintenant ça se fait plus
je crois non
je crois deux ou trois à TF1 après il y
avait je présente une émission un jeu
télé qui s'appelait allo quiz à l'époque
je me rappelle le même studio oui
j'étais en fait deux donc c'était une
quotidienne donc j'étais payé tous les
jours pour faire cette émission là et
j'étais j'étais bien payé j'avais bien
négocié et puis après à cette époque là
j'avais fait aussi quelques prime avec
Jean-Pierre Foucault et les prime on
était super bien payés à l'époque je me
souviens je crois que j'avais 20000 part
près comme ça mais je me suis fait
vous aviez combien Benjamin pour un
prime sur TF1 il y a 4000
avoir j'ai dû avoir 30 30000 € hors
taxes
c'est entre 15 et 20000 ça dépend par
rapport à ce qui rapportait je trouve
que c'est ah oui non mais c'est
n'importe quoi mais je me levais tous
les matins hyper tôt
[Applaudissements]
pour gagner ce que tu gagnes en un mois
non mais je mets je viens de calculer je
mets 2 ans et demi pour gagner ce que tu
gagnes
c'était énorme mais à l'époque j'avais
je venais d'avoir mon fils donc j'avais
23 ans donc tu imagines à 23 ans c'était
la folie quoi c'était la 23 ans quand
j'ai commencé la télé donc c'était sur
France 2 à l'époque je gagnais 4000
francs par mois sur M6 je gagnais
beaucoup moins mais après TF1
ou alors une très bonne chronique merci
merci
[Applaudissements]
j'étais assistante au départ
lui gentiment c'est le Jordan de luxe
excusez-moi c'est en moi je me souviens
que croyez moins que la personne qui
était au standard pour le télé pour les
téléspects
de la politique
il a tellement embêté tout le monde avec
la question en face à face
ah non non non non non
non non non non
[Applaudissements]
alors première question
qui prenait l'émission sur C8
sur le montage avec H2O donc avec Cyril
Hanouna quelle est la marge de
l'émission oh non non mais pourquoi
je rigole il est pas bien
Benjamin si tu continues apparemment
apparemment ils sont pas producteur
en fait il est pas composé en plus
vous êtes payé en tant qu'animateur en
tant qu'animateur je gagne à peu près
4400 euros par mois 400 m par mois voilà
c'est ce que je veux faire
animal et tu ajoutes
producteurs
tu peux ajouter donc ça monte comme ça
Jean-Pascal quelle est la somme la plus
importante que vous ayez quand quand ça
marchait très fort
à peu près à la sortie de en tout avec
les disques j'ai pris 300000 balles
c'est le plus gros que j'ai pris ouais
200000 €. 300000 € ouais pardon pas mal
après il faut enlever la moitié pour
pour les impôts même un peu plus oui
mais c'est oui mais dans l'esprit des
gens oui c'est ça
après on va dire la moitié 150000 mais
j'ai tout c'est ce que j'ai dit j'ai
tout cramé je tout dépensé moi ouais
quel est le plus gros cachet que vous
avez touché Béatrice j'ai tous les faire
le plus gros cachet j'adore cette façon
le plus gros cachet au cinéma on se
régale alors
au cinéma il faut savoir que
ma grand-mère etc
plus alors on gagne plus un télé en tout
cas j'ai parce que j'ai travaillé donc
j'étais 12 ans aux États-Unis en télé et
au cinéma on gagne plus en télé quand on
n'est pas une immense star type Angelina
Jolie ou on gagne 20 millions par film
il vaut mieux faire des séries télé
parce que on est payé par épisode
exactement
la télé c'est très très bien
par jour
c'est par épisode
ou alors des contrats publicitaires
[Applaudissements]
elle est pas bien 45000 par épisode
une semaine et c'est énorme et après il
y a les ventes dans ils peuvent le
vendre ils veulent vendre les séries
dans le monde entier
au bout d'un moment en fait le contrat
c'est pour un passage ou pour tant de
passage
un petit truc
mon plus gros cachet c'est quand j'ai
été licencié du Parisien
ami
on charrie beaucoup et kidia mais j'ai
très pendant 7 ans sur cette chaîne et
franchement c'est la chaîne qui m'a le
plus payante je travaille sur M6 je
travaille sur France 3 pour NRJ 12 j'ai
travaillé pour pas mal de chaînes mais
Equidia ont franchement je gagnais très
bien ma vie et je gagnais je vais vous
dire je gagnais 700 euros par jour
puisque je présentais une émission en
direct tous les jours et je travaillais
tous les jours donc
ça fait combien Benjamin ça fait 3500
balles par semaine ça fait voilà à 14000
balles par mois ça va vite
c'est pas que parce que j'ai compté que
j'ai su gardé mon oseille par exemple
et vous j'en ai congé vendu ma BM 328i
voilà j'ai vendu 6000 euros
et vous Benji c'est quoi la plus grosse
somme vous ayez perdu
[Rires]
en terme de perte j'ai plusieurs
catégories nous avons la catégorie
divorce
la catégorie je sais pas nous avons la
catégorie arnaque
et nous avons la catégorie gros cadeau
et si on faisait un cumul de toutes ces
catégories dans l'émission
[Rires]
c'était à coup de millions bah c'est
quoi c'est à dire qu'au bout d'un moment
quand on t'en fait 4 forcément des
divorces ou 3 3 4 non alors on est pas
chez Jordan de luxe c'est moi qui pose
des questions donc voilà donc la plus
grosse perte la plus grosse perte
j'ai perdu
les cadeaux à la con que j'ai fait à des
gens qui les méritent pas
regretter un cadeau
tu as fait quelque chose
j'avais un associé pour le remercier de
de son travail je vais vous faire une
Ferrari par exemple mais vous êtes fous
moi je veux bien de votre ami c'est vrai
150000 € une Ferrari
de la boîte non après après on s'est
fâché il m'a fait un procès pour me
récupérer un peu plus d'oseille je suis
vraiment un connard et bien il est là
et voilà donc voilà c'est ça